demain qu'on en parle aussi parce que
évidemment c'est pas un sujet qui est
très drôle cette semaine on a appris par
jean pierre pernaut qui a parlé qui a
dit qu'il avait un cancer et qu'il en a
parlé lui-même
il ya eu aussi à l'époque laetitia milot
après laetitia milot enora malagré là
c'est lorie pester
voilà qui révèle sa maladie regarder les
images on en parle est derrière est ce
que vous êtes choqués là aussi pas
choqué ce qu'une stratégie marketing
derrière est ce que c'est un peu glauque
ou pas regardez voilà tu as de
l'endométriose tu as 36 ans aussi est il
serait peut-être bien d'aller quand
j'étais au rct
c'est l'info choc de la semaine la
chanteuse lorie en pleine promotion de
son autobiographie les choses de ma vie
s'est confié à plusieurs micros sur
l'endométriose maladie qui rend la
maternité quasi impossible
alors j'ai décidé d'en parler
aujourd'hui parce que je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait énormément de
femmes qui étaient dans le même cas que
moi
laurie nous parle sans détour car
aujourd'hui quand on est une
personnalité ont tout enfin évoqué sans
tabou sa maladie en public
et ça c'est nouveau et cela ne concerne
pas que les femmes
cette semaine encore l'indéboulonnable
présentateur jean-pierre pernaut a
annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux avoir
subi une opération
j'ai en effet subi une intervention
chirurgicale pour un cancer de la
prostate
vous pensez après une telle annonce les
amis de jean pierre pernaut ont envoyé
leurs messages de soutien à l'animateur
certains ont même rassurer sur sa santé
à l'antenne c'est vrai qu'on embrasse
jean pierre pernaut qui virent être
opéré tout s'est bien passé rassurez
vous au final une chose nous intrigue
pourquoi les stars n'ont plus aucun
tabou a révélé leur maladie
[Applaudissements]
c'est très grave et on embrasse tories
et percussions dans le sujet il ya aucun
jugement là-dessus la question qu'on se
pose évidemment c est ce que les stars
communique sur la maladie par vraiment
par transparence et pour aider les gens
qui ont la même maladie ou est-ce qu en
fait n'existe pas tout simplement bas la
principale va finir par le sortir un
petit peu comme à l'époque de jacques
delors qui avait dû sortir son révélé
son cancer parce que papa paradis
s'était procuré son dossier médical
est ce qu'ils disent pas tout simplement
la presse people va le sortir donc
autant que je le fasse moi même et qu'en
plus ça fasse un buzz un peu positif
autour de moi sébastien ce que c'est pas
ça la vraie raison ou est-ce que la
vraie raison je la connais pas mais je
suis quand même très étonné ce déballage
parce que il faut il faut savoir et là
mes amis sivom démentir que dès qu'on
parle de la moindre chose insignifiante
sur eux un petit flirt une histoire etc
il dégaine les avocats dans tous les
sens et là c'est quelque chose de pour
moi beaucoup plus intime ou à la limite
nous on irait moins et ça il le déballe
régulière c'est qu'ils en parlent même
là bas d'accord il en parlant mais mais
mais alors pourquoi ils sont très
agressifs sur quelque chose
d'insignifiant et ils vont déballer
quelque chose d'ultra intime
ceux qui le disent dans l'autre cas
c'est vous dire ce que je pense qu'après
ce type alors été informé spontanément
de l'endométriose dont la sortie
l'endométriose delory dans closer comme
super fierté on a compté l'opération à
rouen sous les conseils de l'ancien élu
et caetera et son avocat au procès nous
a dit vous montez elle n'est pas malade
ce n'est pas vrai que les seins de la
ville a coûté 15 numéros n'ont jamais
douté 11000 une fois écartées 4500 mais
est ce que vous comprenez que c'est
peut-être à l'ab merouana maladie
vraiment son ami qu'attiser je sais
c'est au riz pour elle de parler de ça
justement
ou alors peut-être que là on l'a fait
changer d'avis peut-être est-ce que la
catalan par leur disant j'ai 36 ans je
trouve ça normal d'en parler enfin alors
que laetitia milot on parle très bien et
depuis très longtemps et l endométriose
vous savez on connais bien maintenant
grâce à laetitia milot qui est vraiment
porte combat depuis très longtemps même
jeune laurie dans ce combat là
maintenant alors je vous remercie on a
toujours besoin je trouve moi je vous
trouve hyper dur avec elle à quoi je
suis peut-être un peu naïf mais je pense
que le
fondard générosité sa tâche s'est
compliquée et je trouve ça très très
indécent de d'imaginer que c'est un
calcul pour se faire connaître
ah non je partage assez la vie de
guillaume concernant laetitia milot
concernant enora malagré concernant
aussi comme elle s'appelle laurence
boccolini qui à part les toits maladie
sur les réseaux je pense que c'est
vraiment pour aider à la vente est
effectivement que la presse people ne
s'en emparent c'est vraiment pour aider
aussi toutes les personnes parce
qu'elles ont énormément de followers